[Music]
welcome back everyone it's charlie
breaking news the flash movie director
just announced that ben affleck was
coming back for the flash movie and he
said how he's gonna fit into the justice
league flashpoint story of it all with
michael keaton's batman so of course
we'll break it down there's a whole
bunch of easter eggs
and there's gonna be a bunch of movie
trailers coming this weekend
the batman movie wonder woman 1984 the
justice league snyder cut trailer so be
sure to subscribe to get all those
videos of course i'll be covering all
those things
we'll do a new amazon giveaway all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and let me know what you think about ben
affleck coming back as
batman so we'll just start at the
beginning here with the big stuff and
number these as we go along
andy muschietti the flash movie director
released a statement when he announced
ben affleck's batman was returning for
the movie
and he said he just recently sent ben
affleck a copy of the flash movie
scripts and pretty quickly after that he
agreed to be in the movie after reading
the scenes that they had written for him
so this is me reading the director's
statement about ben affleck coming back
he says
his batman is a dichotomy that is very
strong which is his masculinity
because of the way he looks and the
opposing figure that he has and his
jawline but he's also very vulnerable
he knows how to deliver from the inside
out that vulnerability
he just needs a story that will allow
him to bring that contrast
that balance he's referencing the news
story that they wrote for him during the
flash movie
so then he goes on to say he's a very
substantial part of the emotional
impact of the movie for anyone that's
watched the justice league flashpoint
movie you also understand this too
the interaction in the relationship
between barry allen and affleck's wayne
will bring an emotional level that we
haven't seen before in the movies
it's barry's story but the characters
are more related than we think
batman and the flash they both lost
their mothers and that's one of the
emotional
vessels of the movie that's where
affleck's batman
kicks in so he's just hyping up the
flashpoint relationship of bruce wayne
batman
in the flash everyone remembers the
flashpoint ending scene where he gives
batman the letter from his father thomas
wayne batman
and makes him cry he made batman cry
batman does not cry which is why the
emotional payoff was so huge in that
moment
it's all about learning to deal with the
trauma of losing their parents batman
deals with it in a very different way
from the flashlight the flash literally
tries to go back in time to prevent his
mother from dying
batman tries to turn all that anger and
grief into justice
i know there's a lot of questions about
how they're going to adapt the original
justice league flashpoint story for the
movie because they did say there would
be a lot of changes from the original
story and they have all the new michael
keaton batman stuff going on from the
multiverse during the movie
so four they confirmed that they're not
doing the big thomas wayne flashpoint
batman part of the original story
before all the michael keaton batman
announcements i had actually assumed
that they'd bring back jeffrey dean
morgan as batman because he played
thomas wayne during batman v superman
and he said himself that he would love
to play flashpoint batman in the dc
movies
but that kind of went out the window
with keaton's batman coming in and even
though i'm disappointed that they're not
going to do flashpoint batman
bringing michael keaton's batman back is
still really really cool
two words that i want you all to
remember they're very important if i
leave you with anything
i'm gonna leave you with these two words
and those two words are i'm batman
the director did confirm they're doing
the core elements of the flashpoint
story reverse flash kills barry's mother
barry goes back in time to try and save
her but they're adding in all this
multiverse story that wasn't part of
flashpoint
flashpoint was an alternate timeline
created when flash saved his mother
but the way they explained time travel
in that original story
is that he didn't create a whole new
alternate reality that existed parallel
to the original one he just rewrote the
original timeline
they kind of use back to the future time
travel roles which avengers end game
most of you know the marvel movies kind
of pissed on
the way that they chose to explain it
was the alternate timelines theory
saying that you can't actually change
the past you can only create
alternate timelines that branch out from
that original moment
so the flash movie director didn't
explain how they're going to do the
multiverse of it all or if that's gonna
happen in present day or if the
flashpoint timeline will be like a
parallel universe
but the multiverse is a very common
thing for the flash ezra miller had this
big long interview a couple years ago
where he went on and on about how
they're introducing the multiverse
during the movie i've done a couple
videos about that because he's kind of
funny during the clip
the flash was actually the first person
in dc comics to travel the multiverse
one day he just accidentally travels to
earth 2 and met the jay garrick flash
and learned about the justice society
alternate versions of the characters
from the golden age
so in the flash movie when the flash
travels the multiverse and meets michael
keaton's batman it'll be the present day
keaton batman of that alternate world
the world of the tim burton batman
movies and he'll be the older batman
beyond bruce wayne
the flash movie director teased that
he'd have some stuff to show off some
concept
art during dc fandom this weekend and
there were some rumors that keaton's
batman costume during the movie would be
the harness from kingdom come
like the much more armored up version of
batman there was a big crisis on
infinite earth's deleted scene for
michael keaton
they originally planned for him to be
the version of kevin conroy's batman
during that wearing the kingdom come
harness but i guess the keaton turned
them down
i did a big deleted scene video for that
so i'll post a link for it in the
description
but number three really important point
here the movie is not going to use
flashpoint in ben affleck's scenes just
to retcon him out of the dc eu
because that's kind of what flashpoint
does they use it for retconning things
the main justice league earth batman
will still be ben
affleck after the movie michael keaton's
batman isn't going to rewrite that
history
he'll just coexist and be another
version of a batman from the multiverse
when he shows up again in another dc
movie
but that being said this is being
pitched as ben affleck's
farewell movie as batman his last major
appearance in a big dc movie
and he's not supposed to be coming back
in the batman costume
he's supposed to be coming back as bruce
wayne in the movie so it's them giving
him a proper goodbye
as batman because he is back during the
justice league snyder cut movie
but all that is stuff that he's already
filmed a long time ago it's old footage
and it was intended to set up a bunch of
justice league sequels so the flash
movie is just giving him a legit ending
but just to be clear they're not killing
or retconning his batman they'll just
give him an out point and explain
why it is that michael keaton's batman
is just gonna start showing up
a lot more all of a sudden the director
didn't give any big spoilers away as to
whether ben affleck's batman will meet
michael keaton's batman or if it's just
the flash who will meet him but it would
be cool to see ben affleck share some
screen time with keaton's batman
so number two when it comes to ben
affleck's actual scenes in the movie
just expect a modified version of that
original justice league flashpoint
ending scene with the letter
the director talked about how much
batman and the flash share in common the
tragedy of both losing their mothers
everyone posts all your martha memes
again but in the justice league snyder
cut and in the theatrical cut batman was
kind of a mentor to the flash because he
was so fresh he hadn't even started
calling himself the flash yet that was
the whole thing during the crisis on
infinite earth scene the flash wow
that's a cool name
but ben affleck's batman was teaching
him how to save people day one superhero
school stuff
so imagine that ben affleck's batman and
michael keaton's batman
impart some wisdom to the flash about
dealing with the trauma of losing your
parents as a child
because you have to remember that
everything that happened to affleck's
batman also happened to keaton's batman
they have the exact same origin story
but also don't be surprised if they have
a little bit of fun with that idea too
the twist of the batman letter instead
of older batman thomas wayne giving
advice to his son bruce wayne batman
you have ben affleck's batman getting
advice from an older version of himself
just from the multiverse who looks a
little bit different bruce wayne is in
his 80s during the batman beyond
series but keaton is going to be playing
him in his 60s
still old man batman but not quite as
old as he was during the tv series
in number one as for live action batman
beyond dc
fandom is this weekend and the flash
movie director like you said did have
some stuff to show us
so i'm hoping that includes some concept
art of michael keaton's older batman
in his new batman suit and affleck's
batman in the movie
and maybe what the new flash costume is
going to look like
because he's probably going to show up
in the justice league suit at the
beginning of the movie just because of
the timeline and then over the course of
the film they'll just give him a new one
batman gets a new costume in every movie
so should the flash
and even though i didn't talk about him
during this movie cyborg is also
supposed to be in the flash movie so
there's a whole lot of other stuff
going on during that movie but it's not
coming out until 2022
and speaking of alternate costumes and
multiverse the director didn't say
anything about grant gustin cameo scenes
but i'm hoping that they find it just a
couple
seconds for a quick grant gustin cameo
just to pay off the crisis on infinite
earth scene
barry allen no what does that mean
how can this this should be impossible
now to be impossible now
you don't know about the oh my god don't
do this to me i don't know about the
what
you okay i
told victor this was possible like he
shows up and they just referenced
meeting each other previously
what happened it's a whole thing i'll
tell you in the next movie
by the time the flash movie comes out
they'll also be winding down on the
flash tv show it'll be in its final
seasons
let me know in the comments though what
do you think about ben affleck coming
back we could talk about this
all day but it's going to be crazy this
weekend with the new batman teaser we
have justice league snyder cut trailer
zack snyder himself also dropped a new
teaser this morning i'll do a video for
that that video should post
friday morning there's gonna be a lot of
footage coming really soon
so leave all your video requests in the
comments below but click here for that
full dc
fandom trailer the batman teaser all the
other big trailers they're dropping
and click here for my brand new wonder
woman 1984 trailer video
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe i'll see you guys tonight
[Music]
you